Alice:这睫毛就粘在
Alice: This eyelash just sticks...
Alice:镊子上
Lucia: 我看看还有什么喝的
Lucia: Let me see what else there is to drink.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经哈哈
Lucia: Haha, I'm already... Haha.
Lucia: 啊不过喝的好像大部分在楼上
Lucia: Ah, but most of the drinks seem to be upstairs.
Alice:哎呀哎呀
Alice: Oh no, oh no.
Alice:我要烦死了
Alice: I'm going to lose it.
Tasha: 要换个镊子
Tasha: You need a different tweezer.
Alice:换镊子
Alice:我应该还有别的
Alice: I think I have another one.
Alice:果然有别的
Alice: As expected, there is something else.
Alice: 那我要生气了
Alice: Now I'm going to get angry.
Lucia: 这个绿豆饼是用来吃的还是
Lucia: Is this mung bean cake for eating or...
Tasha: 用来吃的
Tasha: It's for eating.
Lucia: 啊有人想吃吗
Lucia: Ah, does anyone want to eat?
Tasha: 嗯我觉得还可以再来两瓶养乐多
Tasha: Hmm, I think we can have two more bottles of Yakult.
Lucia: 哈哈来两两瓶
Lucia: Haha, two bottles.
Lucia: 什么啊可以可以
Lucia: What? Okay, sure.
Tasha: 哎养乐多啊
Tasha: Ah, Yakult.
Lucia: 帮你拿
Lucia: I'll get it for you.
Lucia: 刚好我在这
Lucia: Just when I'm here.
Tasha: 养乐多哦哦
Tasha: Yakult, oh oh.
Lucia: 那个掉到后面了我先把它拿出来
Lucia: That one fell behind, I'll get it out first.
Lucia: 这个这个绿豆饼是我们直接可以吃
Lucia: This mung bean cake, can we eat it directly?
Lucia: 还是要用来做原料
Lucia: Or is it used as an ingredient?
Tasha: 直接直接吃啊
Tasha: Eat it directly.
Lucia: 哈哈哈get了
Lucia: Hahaha, got it.
Tasha: 夹带了一包私货
Tasha: Sneaked in a private stash.
Tasha: 都被你发现了
Tasha: You found it all.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 就是当我饿了的时候是吃瑞的
Lucia: Just for when I'm hungry, it's for eating.
Alice:好这个又弄在镊子上了
Alice: Alright, this one is on the tweezers again.
Lucia: 谢谢你要喝吗
Lucia: Thank you. Do you want to drink?
Tasha: 我不喝扔的多
Tasha: I don't drink it much, thanks.
谢谢啊好的
Thanks, alright.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 你是不喝酸奶类的制品还是
Lucia: You don't drink yogurt products, or...
Tasha: 我喝纯酸奶
Tasha: I drink pure yogurt.
Shure: 我回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: Welcome.
Shure: 大家好
Shure: Hi everyone.
Alice:喝不了一点
Alice: Can't drink a bit.
Alice:好了你开始吧
Alice: Alright, you start now.
Tasha:  我们开始了贴睫毛大战哈哈哈
Tasha: We're starting the eyelash sticking battle, hahaha.
其他人：我靠哇
Others: Wow.
其他人：这么多吃的啊
Others: So much food!
其他人：昨天还是空的
Others: Yesterday it was still empty.
其他人：我操这他妈捡一分
Shure: 慢慢考呗
Shure: Take it slow and roast.
Jake: 哎你好你好你好
Jake: Hi, hi, hi.
Jake: 你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello
Jake: 你好你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello, hello
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello
Jake: 眼镜呢
Jake: Where are the glasses?
Shure: 眼镜在我包包里
Shure: The glasses are in my bag
Jake: 导出来了吗
Jake: Have you exported it?
Shure: 还没导出来
Shure: Not yet
Jake: 行那你给我导一下
Jake: Alright, export it for me
Shure: 突然发现那什么
Shure: Suddenly realized something
Jake: 卡拉OK OK吗
Jake: Is the karaoke okay?
Alice:你不要把你的睫毛给夹一下
Alice: Don't pinch your eyelashes
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 答辩OK
Jake: The defense went okay
Shure: 还还OK
Shure: Yeah, it was okay
Shure: 安迪人特好
Shure: Andy is really nice
Shure: 他非常有耐心
Shure: He's very patient
Shure: 虽然我答的是一个答辩但是他
Shure: Even though my defense was just so-so
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：学校这是第一天了啊
Other: It's the first day of school, right?
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah
其他人： 那天晚上学姐开了20分钟车
Other: That night, the senior drove for 20 minutes
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah
其他人：然后扣了6分
Other: Then got 6 points deducted
Jake: 卧槽为什么
Jake: What the heck, why?
其他人：因为闯红灯了
Other: Because of running a red light
Jake: 闯红灯
Jake: Running a red light
Jake: 学姐开车闯红灯
Jake: The senior ran a red light
其他人：那天晚上没看见
Other: Didn't see it that night
Jake: 哦那也不是他的问题
Jake: Oh, it's not their fault
Jake: 路的问题
Jake: It's the road's fault
其他人：北京的问题
Other: It's Beijing's fault
Jake: 北京的问题
Jake: It's Beijing's fault
其他人：我妈刚才在路上
Other: My mom was on the road just now
其他人： 一路学法减分
Other: Learning the traffic laws to get points back
Alice:他不是会送你一个小的吗
Alice: Doesn't he give you a small one?
其他人：学完法减完分
Other: After learning the law, got a point back
其他人：减了一分
Other: Got one point back
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why
其他人：就让我看交通视频
Other: Just had to watch traffic videos
其他人：考试减了一分
Other: Then took a test and got one point back
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 现在考5分了是吧
Jake: So now we got 5 points, right?
Lucia: 没什么啊
Lucia: It's nothing, really.
Shure: 没醒是吗
Shure: Not awake yet?
Lucia: 啊醒了醒了
Lucia: Oh, I'm awake, I'm awake.
Jake: 打工呢好像
Jake: Seems like working.
Lucia: 我们我们上午已经已经录了一段了
Lucia: We, we already recorded a segment this morning.
Alice:们已经结束一轮活
Alice: We already finished one round of work.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 结束一轮
Tasha: Finished one round.
Alice:结束一轮活动了
Alice: Finished one round of activities.
Jake: 哦对然后现在已经开始主播模式了
Jake: Oh right, and now we're in streamer mode.
Jake: 就是眼镜已经不当眼镜用了就
Jake: So the glasses are no longer used as glasses.
其他人：咱们要导数据吗
Others: Are we going to import the data?
Jake: 要要要这个这个
Jake: Yes, yes, this, this.
Jake: 很重要这个很重要
Jake: This is important, this is very important.
Shure: 这个珍贵素材啊
Shure: This is precious material.
Jake: 好好好行
Jake: Okay, okay, got it.
Jake: 眼镜先给我
Jake: Give me the glasses first.
Jake: 我我先倒一个
Jake: I'll import one first.
Shure: 人类恋爱日常素材
Shure: Human dating footage.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake: 有点牛逼
Jake: That's impressive.
Alice:我要画眼线
Alice: I need to draw eyeliner.
爱Tasha: 我不画
Tasha: I won't draw.
Alice:我可以给你画挑
Alice: I can draw it for you.
Shure: 挑不了能拨的剪不能拨的
Shure: If you can't pick it, you can't cut it.
Jake: 我是在中间哦
Jake: I'm in the middle.
Jake: 我要把这个挪开
Jake: I need to move this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:应该先画眼线再
Alice: Should do the eyeliner first.
Jake: 也可以我觉得对
Jake: That works too, I think.
其他人：要不要再学习学6遍
Others: Should we learn it six times?
其他人：你学一遍扣那个
Others: You learn it once, then deduct that.
其他人：扣一分
Others: Deduct one point.
Shure: 得学
Shure: We should learn.
Jake: 那学6遍不就好了吗是吗
Jake: So learning it six times should be enough, right?
其他人：看它这个意思我个人感觉他是能扣个
Others: From what I understand, it seems like it can deduct...
Alice:我给你画个眼线吧
Alice: Let me draw your eyeliner.
Alice:我自己也不太会画但是我觉得
Alice: I'm not very good at it myself, but I think...
Jake: 来来看看一下
Jake: Come on, take a look.
Jake: 我迭代出来的
Jake: I iterated this.
Alice:算了这个已经画坏了
Alice: Never mind, this one's already ruined.
Alice:哈哈哈翻车
Alice: Haha, what a fail.
Jake: 巧妙啊巧妙
Jake: Clever, clever.
Jake: 巧妙是用的超能力
Jake: The cleverness is in using superpowers.
Jake: 花了2,000块钱
Jake: Spent 2,000 yuan.
Jake: 买了15张SD卡
Jake: Bought 15 SD cards.
Alice:这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice:要不要给你画一个
Alice: Do you want me to draw one for you?
Lucia: 我正在想
Lucia: I'm thinking about it.
Alice:不太会哈哈
Alice: But I'm not very good at it, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈我主要是懒得卸妆
Lucia: Haha, mainly, I'm too lazy to remove my makeup.
Lucia: 因为昨天刚洗完澡
Lucia: Because I just took a shower last night.
Lucia: 然后于是今天就什么都没化
Lucia: So I haven't put on any makeup today.
Lucia: 这样晚上就不用卸妆了
Lucia: That way, I won't have to remove it tonight.
Shure: 这个视频能导出给我一份吗
Shure: Can I get a copy of this video?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 之之后都可以给你们
Jake: You all can get it later.
Jake: 然后但是要处理一下
Jake: But it needs some processing.
Jake: 因为这个文件格式不太对
Jake: Because the file format isn't quite right.
Alice:化坏啊怎么办
Alice: It's messed up, what do we do?
Shure: 好的我只要我昨天晚上
Shure: Alright, I just need it for last night.
Alice:啊化坏了
Alice: Oh, it's messed up.
Shure: 这个绝对有
Shure: This is definitely important.
Shure: 比较重要
Shure: Quite important.
Alice:太低了
Alice: It's too low.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 以后是我的亡妻回忆录
Shure: This is for my future memoirs of my late wife.
Tasha:  下眼线应该粘哪啊
Tasha: Where should the lower eyeliner go?
Jake: 哈哈我草
Jake: Haha, oh my god.
Alice:你已经开始粘下边了吗
Alice: Are you already applying the lower part?
Jake: 录下来了我草
Jake: It's recorded, oh my god.
Alice:你不是还没粘上面呢吗
Alice: Didn't you say you hadn't applied the upper part yet?
Jake: 就是这边硬盘每人有一个
Jake: Each person has one hard drive here.
Tasha: 一定要先粘上面的吗
Tasha: Do you have to apply the upper part first?
Alice:我也不知道可以吧都行
Alice: I don't know, maybe, both ways work.
Jake: 现在都在
Jake: Everything is here.
Alice:哎怎么办画一半不想画了
Jake: 现在都在SD卡里面
Jake: Everything is on the SD cards now.
Jake: 根本导不出来
Jake: Can't export at all.
Jake: 太他妈慢了
Jake: It's so damn slow.
Jake: 15台太慢了
Jake: 15 devices are too slow.
Jake: 我靠妈的
Jake: Damn it.
其他人：导一条的多久啊
Other: How long for one export?
Jake: 呃 1 pens
Jake: Uh, 1 pen.
Jake: 对大概真的就是他说是3个小时
Jake: Yeah, he said it really takes about 3 hours.
Jake: 我估计一个小时
Jake: I estimate an hour.
Jake: 一个小时一台
Jake: One device per hour.
Alice:算了影响全擦了
Alice: Forget it, erase everything.
Jake: 然后我现在就是有这么两
Jake: So now I have these two...
Jake: 就是相当于两波有SD卡
Jake: It's like two batches with SD cards.
Tasha: 算了不贴了
Tasha: Forget it, not sticking it.
Tasha: 好难受啊
Tasha: So uncomfortable.
Jake: 所以说就是换一波下来
Jake: So, switch to a new batch.
Alice:好难画啊
Alice: So hard to apply.
Jake: 然后开始疯狂导
Jake: Then start exporting like crazy.
Jake: 就是在这边就疯狂导
Jake: Just export like crazy here.
Lucia: 这个牌是什么牌
Lucia: What brand is this?
Jake: 对就有轮换的时间
Jake: Right, there's a rotation time.
Tasha: 这个是二奔DK
Tasha: This is Erben DK.
Jake: 不然根本他妈的一个小时导不出来
Jake: Otherwise, there's no way to export in an hour.
Jake: 焦头烂额
Jake: Completely overwhelmed.
Alice:谁来救救我呀
Alice: Someone save me.
Jake: 卧槽呵呵呵呵
Jake: Damn, hahaha.
Lucia: 我并不敢给别人画哈哈
Lucia: 我怕画完之后被别人追着打哈哈
Lucia: I'm afraid they'll chase me after I finish, haha.
Tasha: 豪情壮志的开始
Tasha: Starting with great ambition.
Jake: 好这边硬盘每次开一下
Jake: Okay, open the hard drive each time.
Tasha: 潦草的结束
Tasha: Ending sloppily.
Lucia: 我觉得你们画的挺好看的
Lucia: I think your makeup looks great.
Lucia: 就是那种裸妆的感觉
Lucia: It's like a natural makeup look.
Alice:你不贴了
Alice: You're not sticking it?
Tasha: 贴不上了
Tasha: Can't stick it.
Shure: 中午你点什么
Shure: What are you ordering for lunch?
Jake: 血就是在牙上这边嗯
Jake: Blood is on the teeth here, hmm.
Alice:米村拌饭吃
Alice: Mi Village mixed rice.
Shure: 还没开始吃呢
Shure: Haven't started eating yet.
Alice:还没送到
Alice: It hasn't been delivered yet.
Lucia: 我还没到呢
Lucia: I'm not there yet.
Shure: 这是啥呀
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 这是失败
Shure: This is a failure.
Tasha: 嗯你吃一块
Tasha: Hmm, you should try a piece.
Lucia: 其实还挺好吃的
Lucia: Actually, it's quite tasty.
Tasha: 真的真的
Tasha: Really, really.
Tasha: 你你这是杨老师吃的
Tasha: You're eating what Jake ate.
Tasha: 你尝他吃的
Tasha: Try what he ate.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈我靠
Jake: Hahaha, oh my god.
Tasha: 这还有这还有别的你为什么不尝啊
Tasha: There's more, why don't you try it?
Lucia: 真挺好吃的真的
Lucia: It's really tasty, seriously.
Lucia: 这真挺好吃
Lucia: It really is tasty.
Lucia: 我早上吃了好多块
Lucia: I had a lot of pieces this morning.
Lucia: 真的
Lucia: Really.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 那就好哈哈
Tasha: That's good, haha.
Lucia: 那个锅确实可能导热有点快
Lucia: The pot might be heating up too quickly.
Lucia: 就外面稍微有点焦
Lucia: The outside is a bit burnt.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 对焦的地方就会稍微有一点点苦
Lucia: The burnt parts are a bit bitter.
Lucia: 但是本身就是那些没有被烧焦的地方
Lucia: But the parts that aren't burnt are really good.
Lucia: 真的很好吃
Lucia: Really delicious.
Tasha: 好谢谢你明天还做给你吃
Tasha: Thanks, I'll make it for you again tomorrow.
Lucia: 不用谢真的挺好吃的
Lucia: No need to thank me, it's really tasty.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 发自内心的
Lucia: I mean it.
Tasha: 你是觉得蘸糖好吃吗
Tasha: Do you think it's better with sugar?
Lucia: 我觉得蘸不蘸糖都还不错
Lucia: I think it's good with or without sugar.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 作为一个北方人
Lucia: As a Northerner,
Lucia: 就蘸不蘸糖都没所谓了
Lucia: it doesn't really matter to me.
Jake: 嗯不准抽了上来吧
Jake: Hmm, no more smoking, come on up.
Alice:哈好你先画坏啊
Alice: Haha, okay, you draw first.
Tasha:  啊这个感觉
Tasha: Ah, this feels...
Alice:不会画怎么办
Alice: What if I can't draw it?
Jake: 抽烟被学姐骂是吧
Jake: Got scolded for smoking by the senior?
Alice:画不了
Alice: I can't draw it.
Jake: 学姐不骂你
Jake: The senior won't scold you.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Just leave it like that.
Alice:烦死了
Alice: So annoying.
Tasha: 来打个腮红
Tasha: Come on, let's apply some blush.
Tasha: 再画个眉毛吗你
Tasha: Are you drawing another eyebrow?
Alice:怎么办想把它全擦了
Alice: What should I do? I want to erase it all.
Tasha: 差不多挺好的
Tasha: It's pretty good as it is.
Lucia: 我觉得你这个睫睫毛贴挺好看的
Lucia: I think your false eyelashes look nice.
Tasha: 睫毛贴的挺好看
Tasha: The false eyelashes look good.
Alice:谢谢
Alice:眼线怎么办
Alice: What about the eyeliner?
Alice:给它擦了擦不掉
Alice: I tried to erase it, but it won't come off.
Lucia: 很卷翘很好看
Alice:眉毛吧
Alice: Eyebrows then.
Tasha: 咱俩的笔都是这样子卷起来的是吧
Tasha: Our pencils both twist up like this, right?
Alice:眉毛
Alice: Eyebrows.
Alice:我我没有专门的眉那啥我都是用眼影
Alice: I don't have a special eyebrow pencil, I just use eyeshadow.
Tasha: 哦因为跟你的发色比较接近是吧
Tasha: Oh, because it matches your hair color, right?
Tasha: 你可以用染眉膏
Tasha: You can use eyebrow dye.
Alice:因为我懒得买
Alice: Because I'm too lazy to buy it.
Tasha: 我用染眉膏跟你这颜色还挺近哎
Tasha: I use eyebrow dye that's pretty close to your color.
Tasha: 不是新买的吗
Tasha: Didn't you just buy a new one?
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Alice:是这颜色吗
Alice: Is it this color?
Alice:这颜色跟我头发不太像哎
Alice: This color doesn't really match my hair.
Alice:还可以但我已经画了就这样
Alice: It's okay, but I've already drawn it, so it's fine.
Alice:你是不是一般用黑色的眉毛
Alice: Do you usually use black eyebrows?
Alice:或者棕色的
Alice: Or brown ones?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也
Lucia: Me too.
Alice:两个眉毛一点
Alice: Two eyebrows a little.
Tasha: 明明是我画怎么就变成他自己画的
Tasha: Clearly I drew it, how did it become self-drawing?
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah haha.
Tasha: 人还是习惯
Tasha: People still get used to it.
Lucia: 自己动手丰衣足食
Lucia: Do it yourself for a better result.
Tasha: 下面进行我最擅长的涂口红环节
Tasha: Next, let's move on to my specialty, applying lipstick.
Alice:哈哈好
Alice: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 观摩一下人类珍贵涂口红资料
Lucia: Let's observe the precious art of applying lipstick.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:行那今天就涂这个样子
Alice: Alright, so today's look will be like this.
Tasha: 给自己画个夏至吧
Tasha: Let's draw a solstice for myself.
Alice:所以我就会
Alice: So I just...
Alice:你会化卧蚕吗会
Alice: Can you draw under-eye bags?
Tasha: 我吗嗯
Tasha: Me? Yeah.
Tasha: 我我我觉得我会
Tasha: I think I can.
Tasha: 你相信我吗
Tasha: Do you trust me?
Tasha: 我给你来一个
Tasha: I'll do one for you.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 这个口红颜色好看
Lucia: This lipstick color is nice.
Tasha: 好哈哈
Tasha: Alright, haha.
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: It really looks good.
Alice:跟我那个颜色好像
Alice: It looks like my color.
Lucia: 我我买我买我买
Lucia: I, I’ll buy it, I’ll buy it, I’ll buy it.
Lucia: 口红老是要么就买了颜色深了
Lucia: Lipstick always ends up being either too dark.
Lucia: 要么就买颜色太淡了的感觉
Lucia: Or too light for my liking.
Alice:麻烦麻烦
Alice: It's troublesome.
Tasha: 下我来
Tasha: I'll go next.
Alice:我要我要浅一点的
Alice: I want, I want a lighter shade.
Tasha: 粉色的
Tasha: Pink?
Alice:粉色卧蚕
Alice: Pink under-eye concealer.
Alice:嗯无所谓来吧
Alice: Hmm, whatever, let's do it.
Tasha: 笑吧
Tasha: Smile.
Alice:就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Tasha: 笑笑
Tasha: 不是这个吧
Tasha: Isn't it this one?
Alice:就行就行
Alice: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 笑起来
Tasha: Smile.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 笑
Tasha: Smile.
Tasha: 行吗
Alice:这卧蚕笔还挺好用的
Tasha: 好你相信就好
Tasha: Good, as long as you trust it.
Tasha: 这个像
Tasha: This looks like...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:这什么
Alice: What's this?
Tasha: 那你卧蚕本身就很深呀
Tasha: Your under-eye area is naturally deep.
Alice:这好像眼袋
Alice: It looks like eye bags.
Tasha: 嗯下面就是
Tasha: Hmm, the lower part is...
Tasha: 啊这么深
Tasha: Ah, so deep.
Tasha: 你是不是下手太重了
Tasha: Did you go too heavy-handed?
Alice:我确实因为我没有专门的东西
Alice: I did, because I don't have the right tool.
Alice:但是我一般会把它再擦掉
Alice: But I usually wipe it off afterward.
Alice:我那个小头
Alice: My little brush...
Alice:那个小头在哪里
Alice: Where is that little brush?
Alice:啊我一般在用这个把它给涂掉
Alice: Ah, I usually use this to cover it up.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 修硕啊
Tasha: Shure
Tasha: 修硕你会打麻将吗
Tasha: Shure, do you know how to play Mahjong?
Shure: 会啊
Shure: Yes, I do.
Tasha: 我们下午要收集一些麻将素材
Tasha: We need to gather some Mahjong materials this afternoon.
Lucia: 我们下午要收集一些麻将术
Lucia: We need to gather some Mahjong techniques this afternoon.
Tasha: 你愿意
Tasha: Are you willing to...
Lucia: 你运气太好了哈哈哈
Lucia: You're so lucky, haha.
Shure: 太好了
Shure: Great.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 就等这个呢
Shure: I was just waiting for this.
Katrina: 饭来了二楼吃还是这边吃
Katrina: The food is here, are we eating on the second floor or here?
Tasha: 应该是在2楼吃吧装满
Tasha: We should eat on the second floor, right?
Katrina: 你们在干嘛
Katrina: What are you guys doing?
Tasha: 录化妆数据
Tasha: Recording makeup data.
Lucia: 化妆哈哈
Lucia: Makeup, haha.
Shure: 上楼
Shure: Let's go upstairs.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure: 去哪吃二楼
Shure: Where are we eating? Upstairs?
Tasha: 可以要不要
Tasha: Sure, do you want to...
Tasha: 呃先吃饭先
Tasha: Uh, let's eat first.
Tasha: 不涂口红了吧
Tasha: No more lipstick, right?
Alice:不涂腮红结束
Alice: No more blush, we're done.
Tasha: 你这一盘化所有
Tasha: Did you apply everything in this round?
Alice:我没有东西吗
Alice: Do I have anything left?
Tasha: 人果然更喜欢给自己花
Tasha: People really prefer spending on themselves.
Lucia: 那我买一个星空灯
Lucia: Then I'll buy a star lamp.
Lucia: 放在房间里就可以了哦
Lucia: Just put it in the room, and it's done.
Lucia: 我们是不是现在不讨论这个
Lucia: Aren't we not discussing this now?
Alice:你说可以吗
Alice: Do you think it's okay?
Tasha: ok夹子
Tasha: Okay, clips.
Lucia: 再把这个也去了吧
Lucia: Let's remove this too.
Alice:也不录了
Alice: Not recording anymore.
Lucia: 我们是不是可可以把它停一下
Lucia: Should we pause it for a bit?
Alice:嗯充电
Alice: Yeah, to charge.
Lucia: 没有吃饭的时候再录呗
Lucia: We'll record again after lunch.
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Alice:好妆前妆后拍一下哈哈
Alice: Alright, take a before and after makeup shot, haha.
Tasha: 拜拜
Tasha: Bye-bye.
Alice:拜拜吃饭
Alice: Bye-bye, let's eat.
Lucia: complete recording
Lucia: Complete recording.
Lucia: 我们上午这些数据
Lucia: These data we collected this morning...